obrigado
muito boa noite obrigado a todos por
estarem aqui hoje connosco é como manda
muito bem e me apresentou vou falar um
pouco convosco sobre o mix perfeito para
foi assinado
vou falar de demora e vou falar eu
também fui cidade e por isso mesmo
vocês devem entender que eu me sinto um
pouquinho como uma fraude por estar aqui
a falar convosco sobre dois temas que
vocês conhecem a mãe e conhecem tão bem
porque é um quarto destas aula deve amar
esse era maso e sequer foi esta mãe por
isso e outra parte a ansiar ter um amor
e afiar ser amado ou seja eu fui por
isso eu presumo que todos aqui todos nós
que estamos aqui nesta sala
sabemos muito bem e perfeitamente sobre
o que é que eu vou estar aqui a falar
convosco quem não sabe o que é o amor é
um sentimento de ver é o now ea
emocional e por isso é sentimental é um
sentimento de todos nós sentimos
sentimos o palpitar do corpo do coração
sentimos a nossa tela piá e o que é
influenciado os livros ensinam-nos que
foi se da afam pequenos momentos
a felicidade não é eterna não é vivida
em toda a nossa vida temos pequenos
momentos de suicidar em que se rende
ou seja foi ser a alegria quando eu
comecei a escrever que é uma paixão que
eu tenho há uns anos atrás com saia
queria pesquisar um pouco sobre o que é
isto de amor e felicidade o que é
humanizado entendo porque eu sabia o que
era para mim mas eu tinha que escrever
para os leitores não era então o que é
isto
não sei pesquisar e todos os livros me
diziam estas dimensões que agora acabei
de dizer então comecei a pensar assim
tão fácil ter fluência temos momentos de
alegria sorriso nos armarmos e seus
amados porque nós não somos felizes
porque se vocês analisarem as pessoas
que o jogo daí rodeiam desculpa é sempre
um amigo
eu ao ver o facebook do flamengo x toda
a gente se queixa da vida nós estamos
sempre cansados passamos a vida a
procurar uma suíte da vida passamos a
semana inteira à espera de sexta-feira
para sermos felizes do sábado para
estamos a brincar com as crianças do
domínio para usar família e e são esses
momentos depois inatos na alegria porque
não somos fluídos todos os dias
então comecei a fazer pesquisas
comecei a pesquisar na internet
essencialmente em livros de autores de
literatura não só nas finais com também
estrangeiros sobre o que os vizinhos
sobre uma lei foi assinado
encontrei um estudo particularmente
interessante que estava partilhar
convosco
embora muito brevemente um estudo da
universidade de harvard que em 1938
civil estudar 700 pessoas 700 indivíduos
de duas classes sociais bastante
disperso parte dos indivíduos tenha
proveniência do mar faixa econômica e
social bastante renovada e outra parte
de uma faixa social bastante mais baixa
com um pouco a pouco a capacidade
econômica estuda início em 1938 e ainda
continua a ser feito o que é fantástico
porque é um estudo sobre foi será que já
tem 36 anos é talvez o maior estudo
comportamental que existe neste momento
é muito interessante quando conhecer
mais sobre esse estudo e não vou mostrar
muito com as conclusões que há uns
conseguem retirar ao longo dos anos
nesse estudo a ser muito curioso que
eles não estudam só as 700 pessoas que
inicialmente contavam estudar já estudam
os filhos e os netos de muitas dessas
pessoas é algo fantástico tudo isto para
descobrirmos qual é o caminho da foi
final então continuando eles conseguiram
descobrir já no final de fazer em
algumas entrevistas com essas pessoas no
final conquistarem com elas chegaram à
conclusão que todas elas
andem a pergunta funcionar quase da
mesma forma
basicamente para eu ser influentes as
suas relações têm que ser boas relações
eu se classificam à bom dado como o
ponto máximo para ter influenciado para
sentir em momentos de alegria e isso é
fantástico
todos vocês devem estar a pensar que
isso é muito básico e eu disse que eu ia
ser uma prova eu avisei que o próprio
quando comecei a ler esse estudo não
fiquei muito satisfeita porque bundada
foi assinada pelos nosos com os outros a
cae
vamos procurar mais alguns encontrei
outros títulos não de uma só com isso
neste momento ficará para uma próxima
vez se deus quiser mas quem quis
partilhar esta porque realmente é algo
inédito
quando cheguei ao final desta análise se
tornou a perguntava atendimento
então no final porque nós não somos
fluídos que vivemos anciosos porque
fazemos listas enquanto as pessoas que
fazem listas diariamente
não acredito que muitos poucos
levantaram o braço listas para o
supermercado legistas para o mesmo estas
para o ano para as férias para as
crianças para o trabalho
nós fazemos listas que aqui tem pinto é
incrível são mais que eu acho que a
petrobras porque as pessoas fazem listas
ao contrário no pinto chefe nós
conseguimos encontrar e mesas pessoal as
mesmas famílias paulistas como fazer
hoje espancado como fazer listas para
fui cidadão quando eu vi isso pois meio
como fazer listas para filmes irá abrir
foi caiu e então o que é conselhão todos
nós estamos nesta sala diariamente não
fazenda profissional colocamos um
tracinho e um tópico com letras
maiúsculas ser fui obrigada obrigada
ajudou me imenso duas palavrinhas luís
o que eles querem dizer continua a
pesquisar pesquisar e uns anos atrás uma
frase com a qual não concordo
aí lembrei dela no momento em que
comecei a ver essas listas espalhadas
por todo lado
os servidores a frase antes do mais
vamos perguntar se vocês já conhecem
quem é que conhece aquela frase é muito
nas redes sociais christi - expectativas
- decisões last station leste de los
angeles
quem é que joga esta frase eu já fui eu
leio estes dias no instagram
quanto menos expectativas nós tivermos
menos dizer os extremos que eu esta
frase quem é que concorda com esta frase
se as nossas expectativas forem baixas e
os leões também serão machos ao que é
mau
quem concorda quase grande parte da sala
com cola
há uns anos atrás eu esta frase de
sculley completamente eu não conseguir
encontrar lógica porque me sempre me
ensinaram desde a escola primária que eu
tinha contato com os meus sonhos que
tinha expectativa de vida a estudar
tinha que lutar por aquilo que eu
realmente queria e há uns anos atrás
quando iniciar um negócio com meu pai e
ou a fazer as minhas tarefas diárias e
quando apresentava projeto meu pai ouvia
uma filha tu sonhas muito alto
o filho não faça disso um sonho muito
aos outros sonhos mais não pode ser
agora que a chapa a dez anos atrás e eu
não conseguia compreender o meu coração
não entendia que o meu sonho é ter um
teto porque o meu pai me dizia que eu
tinha que assinar mais baixo
tinha que permanecer para nunca
concordei confesso mas também nunca
pensei muito sobre o assunto e apenas
não concordava com uma frase entrar nem
nunca entrou lourenço mas comecei a dar
valor quando fazia questão porque nós
não somos felizes quanto para ser feliz
basta sermos bondosa cultivarmos boas
relações que temos pacientes claro
então comecei a desenvolver em mim uma
resposta interior conjugado com todas
respostas que amplia dos estudos que eu
comecei a fazer
nosso problema não está em ter altas
expectativas
o mais expectativa de com baixas de los
angeles
o nosso plano está em gerir a diesel
usando para essa frase é apenas para nos
confundir alguém escreveu para ser mais
fácil viver
nós tivemos mais expectativas não sabia
usar um caso as expectativas no qual
romário será mais a nós seguimos nossos
sonhos e deixarmos a nossa expectativa
vem subindo e parando lá em cima
a desilusão se alguma coisa não correu
mal também será maior e irá entrar no
fundo o mesmo rumo
nós humanos temos que não queremos
sofrer revisões não quer dizer que não é
por isso que nós não usamos para não
sofrer teológica mim não faz muita
lógica fugir da infelicidade e então não
ser feliz seja é quase então
apresentando um mix e falando muito
rápido cheguei à conclusão que tal como
as mulheres da vida que entram que
assistiu uma apresentação fantástica
cuidado tal como elas enviam os seus
homens para o mar e mantém a expectativa
alta porque a expectativa dela é maior é
que os levassem com vida é maior
expectativa que ela está em qual foi a
maior de usando que não regressem
elas não querem saber elas têm que ter a
expectativa no alto para ser influentes
e viver refletir com a sua família e com
seus filhos enquanto eles não estão cá
outra forma elas não sabem viver e acho
que um dos maiores erros do ser humano
neste momento é não aprender com estas
gerações para eu quero ter flash o que
se foi isto que se foi isto que nós
queremos e foi existem inúmeros caminhos
para foi tirada aqui dentro desta sala
todos nós gastamos para o passado para
estas gerações têm violência e que não
tem mesmo de expectativas e sonhos e
esperar que o melhor pode acontecer é
deixar sugestões fluírem
se nós aprendamos com ela tínhamos
apenas um caminho universal para foi
retirado e parece um pouco pois eu estou
a dizer nós tínhamos um caminho
universal e para lá que caminhávamos
relaxávamos exigiu hoje todas que
viessem porque nós estaremos mais fortes
expectativas poderiam ser mínimas mas os
resultados seriam máximo então tirando
amor amando sendo amado permitam ser
fluence e chegar à conclusão que nós não
nos permitimos ser fluence nos
permitimos a deixar que os momentos de
alegria e nos satisfaça em pleno para
minha felicidade pode ser o sorriso de
um filho para outra pessoa pode ser o
sucesso na carreira foi diferente para
todos nós deixamos de fazer listas nas
páginas tantas a nossa vida não passa de
uma lista de afazeres e isso não vai
ficar a minha proposta eo meu estudo
baseia-se em que fui tirada por ser afro
na a terça a quarta a quinta a sexta ao
sábado e ao domingo e essa é a mensagem
que eu queria deixar o mix para foi
retirado
são 77 dias da semana viva o luxo
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]